bienvenue sur public sénat pour les
duels des sénatoriales européenne les
duels de sénateurs l avant évidemment le
premier rang de septembre prochain nous
vous donnons rendez vous pour quatre
duels quatre débats avec les grandes
voix du sénat est aujourd'hui pierre
laurent bonjour bonjour secrétaire
nationale du parti communiste et
sénateur de paris face à vous jean
michel baylet sénateur du tarn et
garonne et président du parti radical de
gauche alors nous allons revenir sur la
réforme territoriale qui vient d'être
examinée en première lecture au sénat
nous allons aussi parler du lit de
l'image du sénat est ce qu'elle sort
affaibli de cette discussion autour de
la décentralisation et puis plus
généralement quel est le rôle quelle est
la place du sénat en 2014 ça va être un
des enjeux des élections sénatoriales du
28 septembre prochain première question
avoue jean-michel ballet avec le rejet
de la réforme territoriale est ce que
cela a donné l'image de l'immobilisme
la moindre des choses quand on n'est pas
d'accord c'est de voter contre c'est le
cas cette réforme est une mauvaise
réforme le sénat n'a débattue une
majorité s'est prononcée contre ce n'est
pas l'immobilisme que de faire vivre la
démocratie ce n'est pas l'immobilisme
que de défendre ses convictions ça n'est
pas l'immobilier mais plutôt le courage
que de décider quand on est dans la
majorité de voter contre une réforme ans
j'ai toujours pratiqué comme ça je vous
rappelle que j'ai voté la réforme
constitutionnelle de nicolas sarkozy
j'étais opposants là je suis dans la
majorité clairement aux côtés près la
république et du premier ministre mais
cette réforme ne me convient pas je
trouve qu'elle est un préparé je trouve
qu'elle tourne le dos à la
décentralisation en conséquence moi même
et mes amis radicaux du rdse nous avons
écrit à laurent comme l'image d'une
france qui est très très difficile à
réformer et ça vient tout vaut toujours
est assez souvent du sénat non mais
d'abord notre opposition à la réforme
territoriale a été accompagnée
systématiquement dans appelle à un débat
sur une réforme nous ne sommes pas
contre une réforme institutionnelle
au contraire nous avons fait beaucoup de
propositions pour ça mais la réforme est
prise dans le mauvais sens
le le transfert de compétences en sera
le second texte est donc selon vous ça
fait partie des incohérences c'est pas
la première parce que je vous rappelle
que depuis maintenant deux ans on a eu
des versions à chaque fois différente on
a voté il ya très peu de temps le
maintien de la clause de compétence
générale on a une réforme qui propose
maintenant la suppression de la clause
de compétence générale le président de
la république a changé d'avis sur la
question sans jamais s'expliquer alors
que c'est une question extrêmement
importante on démarre par le périmètre
des régions et le changement de la date
des élections sans avoir débattu des
compétences des différents niveaux
institutionnels
arrosoir héros on a l'impression qu'on
nous oblige à débattre sapin qu'on nous
oblige à voter à nous prononcer sans
laisser l'espace du débat
il fallait
d'abord lee radicaux sont pour la
réforme mais celle-là est mauvaise et
sur la forme et sur le fond je le répète
elle tourne le dos à la première loi
emblématique de la gauche 1981 la
décentralisation décentralisée c'est de
prendre des compétences de l'état pour
le donner aux collectivités et les temps
a bien besoin de souvent qui se replie
sur ses fonctions régaliennes ça
fonctionnera mieux deuxièmement sur la
forme quand on veut mener une telle
révolution encore faut-il en connaître
les raisons savoir pourquoi le fait
comme on le fait et dans quelles
conditions on le fait cela a été réparé
puisque de pédagogie c'est
l'improvisation la plus totale et puis
il faut quand même tenir compte du fait
qu'il y a des élus qu'il a des
fonctionnaires territoriaux et qu'il ya
des citoyens la moindre des choses quand
même sans perdre trop de temps c'est de
recueillir leurs amis qui consulter ou
pas moi j'ai été consulté en tant que
chef de parti pierre laurent au siège
allemand mais il ya là il y avait une
personne n'a été consulté en france
c'est quand même un peu plus ce débat il
faut que ça parte de la base vers le
sommet mon cal j'étais secrétaire d'état
chargé des collectivités
j'ai créé les communautés de communes et
pourquoi ça marche qui reconnaît de
communes parce que j'avais posé comme
principe intangible que ça devait partir
de la base vers le sommet qu'il fallait
d'abord un accord local réunir les deux
normandies mettre les pays de loire ce
qu'on ne fait pas d'ailleurs avec la
bretagne pour regrouper quel point ça va
de soi mais comme ça d'un coup d'un seul
ou la toux versez tout cela fondé y
compris par les médias y compris par les
médias pas intervenir sur de fausses sur
de fausses affirmations parce que le
millefeuille à la france c'est pas une
exception dans les pays auxquels on
succombe baril ce pagne allemagne grande
bretagne dont on parle souvent et bien
d'abord s'aider pays fédéraux dont
l'organisation du poids n'est pas du
tout la même et deuxièmement en espagne
aux côtés généralités que sa région il y
a les députations qui sur le département
en allemagne il y à l'écran aux côtés
des länder donc tout cela crée une
confusion qui fait que la forme n'est
pas l'eau et le fond non plus parce que
on enlève encore deux des grands
passionné aussi d'aviation c'est
l'autonomie fiscale des collectivités et
la proximité l'activité
est ce que c'est vrai ce que dit jean
michel baylet qui effectivement créé des
grandes régions en france ça veut dire
qu'on irait peut-être plus vers une
fédération de région change un petit peu
la réforme si vous et le change très
bien fondé mon système institutions
et ça mérite ça mérite pour cette raison
un débat approfondi et pas un débat qui
n'est ni qu'ils aient mené voir un
référendum où nous sommes favorables
parce que là on change totalement
l'architecturé institutionnelle d'une
certaine manière si on allait au bout de
la réforme telle qu'elle est proposée
c'est vraiment un changement de
république je la question de la
proximité que soulever jean michel
baylet et est essentiel et tout ce qui
remonte du pays c'est justement une
demande de proximité pour recréer de la
confiance dans la représentation
politique et on sait aujourd'hui qu'en
plus la proximité elle permet de faire
remonter une expertise citoyenne et
populaire qui est très importante dans
la société d'aujourd'hui donc les élus
locaux ont eux mêmes besoins de cette
proximité pour correctement travailler
les parlementaires aussi et là on va se
trouver avec un éloignement considérable
si on fait si on va au bout du processus
engagé on va remplacer dans les très
grandes régions va se retrouver avec des
conseils régionaux de 150 élus sur des
immenses région qui vont remplacer à
terme non seulement les conseils
régionaux actuels mais aussi les
conseils les conseils départementaux
donc on va réduire considérablement les
vendent à mener
avec un dvd avec un risque d'éloignement
dans la maîtrise par les citoyens des
décisions qui sont prises et qu'est ce
qui va remplacer ça parce qu'il faudra
quand même agir dans tout un tas de
domaines le risque est de faire grandir
une technocratie qui va remplacer le
travail des élus et la proximité entre
les citoyens et les élus les dépenses de
consommation jeu sous la question des
départements et sans que ce soit la
droite ou l'art de dire qu'il faut les
en tout cas les fusionner ou en tout cas
les supprimer vous c'est le cheval de
bataille sur lequel voulait pas lâcher
demande d'ailleurs c'est incohérent on
agrandit les régions et on supprime
l'échelon de proximité qui va prendre
les compétences du département vous
croyez que la région moi je suis milieu
n'est inscrit dans la loi dans les
compétences est impossible ces timbres
et moi je suis midi pyrénées qui
déjeunent région de caen dont la
belgique même plus grande on veut
fusionner avec le moteur conscient vous
croyez que depuis toulouse organisé des
transports scolaires par exemple sur une
zone aussi vaste et je pourrais prendre
toutes les compétences pour être social
et autres départements des compléments
n'arriverait pas levé alors peut-être
pour les transports communes et
les intercommunalités
ce qu'il faut c'est considérer qu'il ya
deux sortes de département il y a les
départements métropole là effectivement
on peut considérer que la métropole
devient département il y en a quelques
unes en france mais la ruralité ne peut
pas faire payer une fois de plus les
frais de tout cela qui fait
l'aménagement et irresponsable
oui attendait ce qu'envisage le
gouvernement après bien des débats parce
que nous sommes elle a réclamé à cor et
à cri nous être opposé moi ce que je
pense comme vous retrouvez un accord là
dessus peut-être pas sur le découpage
parce que d'avancer et le dialogue est
très cadenassée mais sur la seconde
partie de ce texte ne peuvent y arriver
pour peu qu'on reconnaisse que le
département avec ses compétences
actuelles est indispensable à la
ruralité au territoire et à la proximité
à les citoyens déjà il ya deuxième de
proximité c'est le maire le conseil
général car j'apprends à passer sur un
sujet économique de toute façon on a
deux on a besoin de trois échelons
institutionnels on peut discuter de ces
échelons de leurs compétences et
d'ailleurs dans toute l'europe
contrairement à ce que je lis ou est ce
que j'entends parfois dans des
raccourcis on a ce type d'organisation
institutionnelle très différentes mais
il ya presque partout trois niveaux
institutionnels
parce que c'est une bonne manière
d'organiser les choses on peut discuter
de leur périmètre on peut discuter de
leurs compétences mais effectivement si
en plus on agrandit les régions et qu'on
supprime les départements on va avoir un
vide d'organisation et au lieu d'avoir
une simplification comme on nous parle
du milf mais non mais on va avoir une
complication on va avoir une
technocratie grandissante on va avoir
une pagaille supplémentaire et on n'ira
pas du tout vers une simple et est ce
que cette réforme va faire des économies
ou pas on va voir l'en quête de l'eau
sybille et puis évidemment on après
interrogé juste après
la normandie deux régions côte à côte
l'union semble évidente dans le projet
de réforme territoriale
et pourtant en 2008 une étude a été
menée pour savoir si cela baisserait les
dépenses publiques le constat est sans
appel la fusion coûterait 15 millions
d'euros et serait amorti en vente aux us
vous avez des économies d'échelle liées
à une mutualisation en fait d'un certain
nombre de travaux de fonction mais ces
économies d'échelle elles sont quand
même limité et cesse et c'est à dire que
si on prend l'exemple des lycées vous
avez des lycées dans basse normandie des
lycées en haute normandie vous n'allez
pas les regrouper pour faire des
économies d'échelle des économies bien
marginale la réforme prévoit de diviser
les régions par deux au total le
gouvernement table sur une dizaine de
milliards d'euros d'ici cinq à dix ans
soit 5 % de la masse globale des
collectivités territoriales chez les
parlementaires de gauche ou de droite
personne n'y croit on nous dit je fais
une réforme pour simplifier les
structures territoriales
et cela va apporter des économies et
qu'on ne soit pas capable
d'articuler clairement ces économies de
les chiffrer
quand on aura uniformiser le régime
militaire des salariés sur huit ou dix
départements dans les nouvelles régions
on sera obligé de faire par le haut donc
au niveau des salariés d'aidé nouvelle
collectivité sans gêne rit beaucoup plus
de dépenses le budget des collectivités
est d'environ 250 milliards d'euros soit
30 milliards pour les régions
165 pour les communes et enfin 30 pour
les départements alors où trouver des
économies là où il ya des économies très
importantes à faire c'est au niveau de
tout ce magma les communes les
intercommunalités
les opci les syndicats mix là il faut
mettre les mains dans le cambouis et
commencer à dire qui fait quoi et à
empêcher qui est un recouvrement et des
compétences et aussi ce qui est plus
grave et qui coûte très cher
actuellement un recouvrement des
décideurs
les collectivités territoriales ont déjà
des budgets très serrés l'état leur
supprime 28 milliards d'euros d'ici à
2017 si la fusion n'est pas une manne
est devront trouver ailleurs les
ressources financières
nous avait vendu au départ une dizaine
de milliards d'économies visiblement à
l'arrivée à pas grand chose
ce chiffre n'a jamais été étayée par
personne il a été lancé à mon robinet
d'ailleurs on a on va saisine ou le
conseil constitutionnel qui affine est
finalement balayé valider le l'étude
d'impact mais dans l'étude d'impact
c'est des questions qui restent très
floues et par ailleurs il ya une autre
question qui est pas du tout étudier
dans l'étude d'impact
c'est ce qui va advenir de l'ensemble
des fonctionnaires exceptionnelle des
fonctionnaires territoriaux ce qui est
un énorme sujet non le risque je crois
parce que si on si vraiment certains ont
l'objectif de faire 10 milliards d'euros
c'est pas parce par simplification c'est
qu'en vérité il y aura évaporation d'un
certain nombre de compétences et d'une
part de l'action publique et là alors
avec des conséquences sur les
populations qui risquent d'être
extrêmement inquiets ces fonctionnaires
qu'est-ce qu'on fait jean michel weill
et parce qu'ils partent à la retraite
ont l'air en place sont pas trop vu
d'ici on nous sommes quand même une fois
de plus sur des choses ahurissantes
parce que monsieur alignerez parler de
12 à 25 milliards d'économies à la
sortie on commence à reconnaître ça
coûtera plus cher c'est une réalité
donc voilà un des deuxième critère qui
justifiait cette réforme qui s'effondre
ces fonctionnaires ils sont toujours
indispensables sauf qu'à part en trombe
et des fusions partie de mon jeu ils ont
des statuts différents selon les
départements les régions on visera
toujours par le haut elle s'y que
d'ailleurs dans les services
départementaux d'incendié et de secours
dom de nour des charges supplémentaires
et pitié alors on avait raison de
souligner que tous les cinq ans
l'évaporation des services publics
aujourd'hui l'état n'existe plus dans
les départements où très peu quand
j'entends me de l'intérieur dire un bar
amener l'état mais avec quels moyens en
un sens
ce
qu'elles soient bien pensé qu'elle soit
cohérente quel est l'accord de celles et
ceux qui sont concernés et qu'on prenne
le temps de la réflexion et de l'action
et simulation je rappelle quand même que
sur la méthode on avait le ski est fort
dans cette histoire si je puis dire
c'est qu'on avait relativement bien
commencé puisque le président du sénat
jean-pierre bel avait pris l'initiative
d'états généraux de la démocratie locale
qui avait permis de faire débattre une
vingtaine à vingt mille élus locaux en
france il y avait eu des états généraux
qui sont acquis ici et électroniques eee
qui disait un certain nombre de choses
qui n'étaient pas qui était assez
valable et puis tout ça a été subitement
rangée on a fait une première réforme
qui n'a pas fonctionné caen qui n'a pas
qui n'a pas abouti on en a fait nos et
puis plus ça avance plus on avance dans
la précipitation parce que vous n'avez
pas un peu on peut quand même qu'on le
temps d'un débat aussi important c'est
pas c'est pas une folie de dire on va
prendre une année entière en des
politiques au sénat de toute façon
n'était pas me verrez des menaces madame
demain aujourd'hui rappelons quand même
qu'aujourd'hui les choses fonctionnent
bien parce que on parle comme si rien
n'allait la conférence alité entrerait
géant département communauté de communes
et communes a trouvé son bon équilibre
pour la plus grande satisfaction de nos
concitoyens si il faut toujours aller là
bas si il faut toujours faire bouger les
choses mais il faut le faire dans la
tranquillité la sérénité et dans la
raison en est qu à la sortie ce soit nos
concitoyens car bénéficie israël
qu'après les élections sénatoriales
tranché vivre et je ne crois après je ne
crois pas de toute façon que la p1
électorale sur la bonne période emmené à
mener de telles réformes bien
naturellement oui mais effectivement ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas mon timing
les précipiter et on al'impression
d'ailleurs qu'il s'est accélérée
subitement après les élections
municipales avec des modifications dans
les orientations qui ont été données par
l'autre par le président de la
république d'abord ensuite par le
congrès ce qu'il faut éviter à tout prix
mais vite à tout prix ça n'a aucun sens
tout le monde est content on allait vite
comme si si c'est pour faire des
réformes et que ces réformes débouche
sur une dégradation de la situation où
est l'intérêt bien sûr qu'il faut la
réforme c'est tout le monde et pour des
réformes mais le problème c'est de
savoir si ces réformes nous nous nous
permettent d'aller de l'avant et ceci au
contraire elle détricote des situations
et pour les rondes kessy circoncire très
simple jean michel baylet est ce que
vous considérez aujourd'hui fait
toujours partie de cette majorité pas si
pareil il paraît vous avez une confirmer
ou pas qu'on assistait même plus aux
réunions alain jean christophe
cambadélis nous ne sommes pas allés ce
matin la réunion du reste de la gauche
rassemblée parce que nous avons un
conflit entre socialistes et radicaux
qui est lié à des accords signés pour
les élections sénatoriales 14 cantons
quand c'est électorale permettez-moi par
lecture animée qui en donne pas son
accord signé des plus hautes autorités
d'ailleurs de l'état y compris grande le
sénat la moindre des choses c'est le
respecter moi je suis clairement dans la
majorité je suis d'ailleurs manuel valls
est clairement prendre soin françois
hollande mais je ne suis pas un godillot
les radicaux leur propre différence sur
les institutions ce n'est pas nouveau
déjà pendant les primaires je m'étais
imposé
également oui elles le sont et ce que je
voudrais dire ce qui est inquiétant
c'est qu'on a l'impression que on les
formations de la majorité se préoccupe
de maintenir la présidence à gauche au
sénat et que à certains niveaux du
pouvoir lui-même ça a pas l'air de
préoccuper grand monde pour un soutien
garder la majorité je viens de vous
confirmer mon soutien si on veut
parvenir saint jory parvenir à maintenir
malgré les débats qui nous traversent
une majorité et présidence à gauche au
sénat la moindre des choses c'est de
discuter d'essayer d'avancer ensemble et
pourtant il ya beaucoup de débats entre
nous c'est vrai mais je pense que nous
devrions être les uns et les autres
occupé de cela or manifestement ça n'a
pas l'air de parler des valeurs et le
pardon vous allez
et de la nouvelle majorité le projet
socialiste mais nous nous nous sommes
nous sommes nous sommes dans la gauche
nous sommes une formation je rappelle
qu'il ya pas de
nom mais pas revoter grand show miam si
on vote on veut beaucoup plus de choses
que ça d'ailleurs que vous allez gérer
que des airs de le dire
oh il ya effectivement des grandes des
cessions auxquelles on n'a pas apporté
notre soutien mais on vote d'autre chose
on a une attitude qui essaye d'être une
attitude constructive et dans le travail
sénatorial tout le monde on peut avoir
des débats blé tout le monde rend qu'il
ait pu nous sommes un groupe qui
travaille jean michel bayle et vous qui
connaissez bien les élections ça
n'attend qu'un certain temps est ce que
vous estimez que c'est perdu pour la
gauche après septembre
la partie n'est jamais perdue par
avancer les choses sont difficiles c'est
incontestable et on vient on vient d'en
donner les raisons elles comme pour les
top pick six filles un peu plus un peu
plus mais je veux revenir sur ce que
vous disiez toute la gauche se trouvent
rassemblés derrière le câblier de la
gauche pour la présidence du sénat soyez
en certains et n'essayez pas de trouver
des dix ans sur lyon où il y en a pas
mais nous ne sommes pas tous les mêmes
nous avons tous notre histoire nos
engagements donc nos convictions et nous
ne sommes pas des godillots au
rendez-vous mais tu sais pas perdu en
tout cas bien sûr merci d'engagement de
toutes nos forces vous savez la dernière
fois
voyez au fait que la gauche pour être
majoritaire au sénat ça a été le cas et
nous serons tous derrière notre candidat
mais ça changera quoi finalement même si
j'imagine que la gauche puisse gagner ou
garder le sénat aujourd'hui cette
majorité elle tient à très peu de chose
d'ailleurs vous a fait partir un petit
peu de ces questionnements ça changera
quoi si la gauche garde le scénario dont
le pays vous savez nous ne sommes pas
des élus
l'air hors de l'art du pays ou de la
société il y a dans le pays je crois une
majorité de gens de gauche qui
continuent d'attendre des décisions
positives et nous menons des débats
parfois des combats et nous soutenons
des choses nous en combattant d'autres
mais nous essayons de créer mon travail
on et travaillons à rassembler des
majorités pour des réformes de
changements positifs dans le pays et ce
combat là ne va pas s'arrêter nous ne
sommes pas nous n'avons pas décidé de
mettre un terme à cet effort politique
là non je vois ça changera beaucoup que
la gauche garde le sénat parce que le
sénat c'est la chambre de la raison
c'est la chambre la tranquillité et
c'est la somme du travail législatif et
le big art imerys m'est indispensable à
la france c'est quand même ici qu'ont
aussi améliorer les textes c'est ici
qu'on sait faire du bon travail qu'il ya
moins de patios et reprenant le terme
moins de précipitation qu'à l'assemblée
nationale non je ne pense pas qu'il soit
menacée mais je répondais à monsieur sur
qu'est ce que ça changera si le sénat
reste à gauche ça changerait beaucoup de
choses ça ne sera pas une chambre
conservatrice a sera une chambre qui va
de l'avant mais qui va de l'avant en
défendant ses propres idées et sa propre
vision de la république ce moment ce que
vous voulez dire 1 chambre de la raison
de la tranquillité c'est l'image qu'elle
a donnée en ce moment le chemin trois
jeux mais c'est sûrement là je le crois
il y à des institutions elles sont
démocratiques il y à des débats
parlementaires le sénat n'est pas
l'assemblée nationale où les choses sont
plus vives et plus clivée ici on essaie
d'aller de l'avant on essaie de 2001
chacun montre selon ses convictions vous
parlez de coalition étrange parce qu'il
se trouve que sur certains autres nous
sommes retrouvés avec d'autres mais ça
s'est fait dans d'autres temps sous
d'autres majorités et ça arrive même à
l'assemblée nationale que les textes
soient adoptés à l'unanimité
mais quand c'est le sénat on veut tout
de suite montré du doigt pour nous faire
passer pour
vous qui êtes quand même sénateur depuis
beaucoup moins longtemps que jean michel
baylet comment vous voyez les choses pic
vous êtes ici aussi au sénat non mais
moi je le jure mais ça n'a jamais non
mais je confirme qu'il ya beaucoup de
travail ici un travail sérieux ouais je
participe régulièrement à la commission
dans laquelle je suis et il ya du
travail
et la question qui est posée il faudrait
la poser à l'envers c'est ce qu'on
respecte suffisamment le travail
parlementaire il y a beaucoup travail
parlementaire oui mais on a un système
institutionnel qui a effectivement d'un
tendance à trop mépriser le travail
parlementaire et si au lieu d'entretenir
un espèce de climat pour des qui
décrédibilise les élus ont valorisé
vraiment en rendant plus plus
transparents on est dans à faire
connaître les travaux parlementaires qui
trop souvent ne sont pas écoutés ne sont
pas écoutés parce qu'ils prennent la
décision finale et la précipitation est
une mauvaise badia de respecter un
travail parlementaire la démocratie
demande du temps mais vous savez tous
les élus locaux et tous les citoyens
comprennent ça quand on veut construire
une décision intelligente y compris dans
une commune comprend le temps pour pour
la construire et le temps ça fait partie
de la démocratie alors il ya un texte
sur lequel le sénat a été pas mal
critiquée c'est quand il s'est opposé à
la limitation du cumul des mandats on a
été voir pour ses duels un certain
nombre de constitutionnel je vais vous
faire écouter philippe blachère alors
lui il était contre la limitation du
cumul ça va vous plaire jean michel
balle et il trouve que ça va fabriquer
des sénateurs hors sol écoutez le
à titre personnel je considère que si le
sénat
représente les collectivités
territoriales de la république il n'y a
pas lieu d'appliquer l'interdiction du
cumul des mandats aux sénateurs si une
réforme devait éventuellement être
appliquée aux c'est là ce serait
peut-être d'introduire un peu plus de
proportionnelle pour permettre à la
pluralité des formations politiques de
pouvoir s'exprimer monsieur le sénateur
comment envisagez-vous d'exercer votre
mandat
si le cumul des mandats s'applique à
votre égard autrement dit peut-on en
france avoir un sénat le dessinateur
hors sol
incompris un jean michel baylet va être
plutôt d'accord un cas mais je me fais
mes yeux la question à poser directement
aussi à pierre laurent le non-cumul
c'était une erreur ou là dessus nous
n'avons pas la même nous n'avons pas la
même position sur la question du cumul
mais je pense qu'il faut la resituer
dans un problème plus global on a un
problème
et qui n'est pas seulement le problème
du cumul la proportionnelle ont fait
partie la proportionnelle ont fait
partie
je pense qu'il manque dans ce pays un
statut de l'élu qui permettrait à
beaucoup de gens d'accéder à cette
fonction là et de pouvoir naviguer de
manière plus facile entre un mandat
d'élu temporaire et le retour et le
retour à la vie professionnelle
donc il faudrait une réforme d'ensemble
est là aussi à ne pas mener la réforme
d'ensemble qui est nécessaire eh bien on
accroît les problèmes et en voulant
régler uniquement un seul problème par
exemple le problème du cumul sans régler
les autres effectivement on prend le
risque d'avoir des effets pervers moi je
suis plutôt favorable au non-cumul et à
la limitation même des mandats dans le
temps
il faut accompagner ça sinon on
stigmatise des élus qui n'ont pas à être
stigmatisée et le problème effectivement
du lien avec les élus locaux est un état
et intégration dans le droit fil de ce
que j'ai dit depuis le début je suis
pour la proximité le jour vous avez des
élus hors sol qui passent leur semaine à
paris d'abord on trouve qu'on légifère
trop alors on arrachera pas les choses
mais deuxième bien il ne sont plus au
comptant des citoyens moi je suis pour
des élus qui ait les pieds dans la
glaise beaucoup de nos problèmes
aujourd'hui viennent du fait qu'il y a
un certain nombre d'apparatchiks partis
politiques de hauts fonctionnaires et et
d'élus pardon bien laurent de la région
parisienne qui ornent colo gaz et
colonisé organisé d'une certaine manière
le sénat et l'assemblée nationale et ça
et ça se ressent dans nos débats et ça
se ressent dans les textes qui sont
présentés je suis pour des élus qui
connaissent la province qui sont au
contact de leurs concitoyens et qui leur
rend des comptes directement de manière
permanente c'est quand on est mère au
canton et conseillera le camp le fait
s'est pas cantonné simplement sénateurs
ou députés dans les dorures de nos deux
pâles et plus largement puisque vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure moi je suis
pas un changement institutionnel je suis
pour la 6ème république parce que le
quinquennal fondamentalement modifier
les choses il faut désarmer il faut
désormais mettre le droit en a pas en
harmonie avec les faits on passe un
régime présidentiel et ont rendu force
les pouvoirs du parlement c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le parlement est
martyrisé et en particules original
puisqu'on nous dit d'une certaine
manière même aimablement mais quand même
ennui de toute façon on est pas d'accord
l'assemblée nationale
civilisée et apaisée actuel qui le dit
on fait l'impasse sur le sénat
finalement oui mais c'est pas un
problème qui
problème qui est lié à ce gouvernement
c'est une dérive tuiles qui a été qui
s'est installée au fil des années et
effectivement je pense qu'on a besoin de
passer il faudra ouvrir un débat
institutionnel global pour construire
une sixième république il ya beaucoup de
choses à repenser il faudrait
effectivement prendre le temps de ce
débat il mener de manière globale et je
pense que c'est un débat qui passionnera
les citoyens les radicaux vent derrière
le faire nous faisons une convention sur
la 6ème république au mois d'octobre
nous sommes
bien invité les autres parties police
mais dans tous les débats qui qui se
mène à gauche cette question est en
train de monter beaucoup de chansons
qu'on qu il y a un problème parce que le
système c'est en somme on boude au bout
d'un système qui devient un système à
bout de souffle et il faut régénérer la
démocratie donc il faut repenser sa de
manière globale nous nous avons fait
aussi des propositions en ce sens nous
travaillons sur ces questions et je le
répète c'est un débat qui intéresserait
les citoyens parce que les citoyens
voit bien au
climat de défiance actuelle absolument
absolument je serais plus utile que
d'entretenir un
cri s'inscrit dans la durée le climat de
défiance actuelle il est il est
conjoncturelle il faut ça mais il faut
effectivement réfléchir aux raisons de
cette défiance sont les hommes qui font
que le parlement marche quand un gars et
il faut donc que nous avancions sur le
passé du jeu voyez que nous sommes bons
informel sont encore beaucoup plus
puissante que celle de fusionner des
régions moi je suis pour le changement
de république je suis pour la 6ème
république et je suis pour une nouvelle
constitution est un peu ça finalement la
vraie révolution alors puis alors
absolument ccic par des réformes
d'ampleur de cette importance qui
prennent les problèmes au niveau où nous
sommes le monde a changé la société a
beaucoup changé il faut quand même
avancer avancer de manière de manière de
manière effectivement radicale mais un
peu le flanc lors de vos différentes
rencontres avec lui notamment sur des
questions posées sur ma position
institutionnelle est connu depuis le
début je l'avais déjà exposé pendant les
premières
depuis et quant à la demande de passage
à une sixième république il ya longtemps
que les radicaux y travaillent nous
n'avions pas été entendus jusqu'à
maintenant nous on se l'était fait un
peu piqué amicalement un moment par en
nommant de bouc et bien nous revenons à
la chance parce qu'on m'a dit il y a
urgence nous avons été reçus par
françois hollande avec les deux
présidents de groupe de l'assemblée et
du sénat nous avons remis à nouveau un
document à françois hollande qui
comporte des propositions pour aller
vers une sixième république des
propositions globales et les critiques
nous faisons aujourd'hui sur la réforme
ou les avions fait tel que telle qu'elle
est engagée aujourd'hui nous les avions
fait en direct ou président de la
république on lui soumet tant d'autres
propositions donc ça n'avait rien à voir
avec une attitude d'immobilisme ou de
blocage nous avions dit un autre chemin
possible merci messieurs d'avoir répondu
à l'invitation de duel on se retrouve au
mois de septembre bien évidemment pour
commenter les résultats des élections
sénatoriales plats épicés duel vous
pouvez les retrouver sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr ils seront
rediffusés sur notre antenne au mois de
juillet mais vous pouvez aussi les
regarder sur notre site internet ainsi
que tout ce qui concerne les questions
les enjeux d sénatoriales du 28
septembre prochain merci à tous les deux
venus sur notre plateau très bonne
journée sur notre antenne
tous